- Wir wünschen guten Appetit!
- Augen auf!
- Paella!
- Wir hoffen, es schmeckt dir.
Du hast ja sicher keine Lust mehr auf
deutsches Essen, oder?
- Ich finde deutsches Essen sehr lecker.
Ich mag Wurst und Rouladen und Gulasch.
Aber am liebsten mag ich Paella!
- Du musst zuerst probieren!
- Hm … Schmeckt wie in Spanien!
- Ha!
- Das ist ein großes Kompliment!
- Spanisches Essen vermiss' ich
manchmal.
- Das versteh' ich …
- Hast du ein bisschen Heimweh?
- Hm? Heimweh?
- Ja, Heimweh. Das ist, wenn man
traurig ist und nach Hause möchte.
- Ach so! Nein, ich hab' kein Heimweh.
Mir gefällt es hier.
Aber meine Freunde vermiss' ich ein
bisschen.
Und das Wetter in Spanien ist besser.
Es regnet nicht so oft und es ist wärmer.
- Ich gehe gleich in Yaras Laden und
gieße da die Blumen.
Willst du mitkommen?
- Ja, gerne.
- Okay. Aber iss erst auf!